please welcome someone i just love so
much and think so highly of toe for
[Applause]
grace yes i love that movie it's so good
to see you topher i'm so happy to see
you i am the eight millionth person
to come on this show and say this is the
truth that you were the nicest human in
definitely hollywood in the world yeah
i see you
say thank you so much on this show to
people all the time but i i don't know
if you remember this you shouldn't
remember this but i remember this
because i
was pulled out of a high school play to
be on saturday i never acted before that
70s show and i saw you at the
nickelodeon's
kids choice award was the first time
ever presented award an awards ceremony
and someone came up to me and said hey
uh
someone wants to say hi to you i said oh
i thought it was maybe like a hollywood
thing and then you were citing different
things i'd done on the show and i drove
home
like whistling i was so like i thought
oh my god someone believes and the fact
that i i mean you were such an icon like
i couldn't believe you were saying that
to me and then and the show did you're
so such a wonderful person so great god
thank you so much for saying that
okay so you did something that just has
had me like all in a blather about
did you crash the academy awards yeah
right so uh how did you do that my i've
been when i was invited but
before i went
i was still at usc and usc used to be
right across the street shrine right
across from the shrine auditorium which
the academy awards was at for decades
and we were like up drinking on a
parking garage yes
i already love this story and my buddy
goes i bet if we just drove a limo in
tomorrow just got in that limo line we
could just hop out of the car
and walk in
and i was like
yeah there that's me oh my god you are a
baby
oh my god you are a true little tiny
baby that's like baby face two months
before i started that seven show we
couldn't even afford it two months
before you had puberty
it's one in the same one
but i
we got in the limo we pulled up we got
out of the car waved everyone in the
audience goes like whoa like who and by
the time they knew that they didn't know
who we were we got in there and we were
on the red carpet we saw tyra banks
which is a big deal for us and then we
saw you
was it the year i had the daisies in my
hand yeah you had i know you got a big
thing for yup
i love it so much budweight good for you
that is
that's the kind of spirit
that speaks to me
i love that moxie that actually
dovetails perfectly into something i
also have to ask you about which is this
text chain
with tom cruise and meryl streep topher
spill it all tell me everything well
look we've been looking for a project
the three of us no we um
i like was bored it was a pandemic i
stole my wife's phone and i made fake
texts where i'm like
this isn't actually from meryl streep i
should say
um where she's just talking about how
much she loves my acting and
tom cruise and i did one from uh daniel
day lewis where he's like teach me like
teach me your ways
like i want to learn how to be a good
actor so wait do you go in your wife's
phone and like create a contact yeah
because it looks legit i love this okay
so if you were to text meryl streep in
real life
what would you say to merrell um oh my
god you're the greatest of all time
sorry for texting you
and tom cruise
i'd say uh take it down a notch dude
you're gonna die
we don't need all these stunts like you
can use your stunt double
[Music]
you